* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Woher ist denn dieses Papier?
Wer hat denn
diese Protokolle verfasst?
Sind das CIA-Dokumente?
Krass.
Dieser Satz ...
Das ist
so was von schlimm geschrieben.
Das überrascht natürlich,
wieso das zur CIA gelangt ist.
Wir hätten auch gerne gewusst,
ob das einen wahren Hintergrund hat.
Aber wir waren nicht
in der Lage, das aufzudecken.
Jahrzehntelang
hat die Welt gerätselt.
Was hat eine kleine Zuger Firma
namens Crypto AG
mit ausländischen Geheimdiensten
zu tun?
Mit der CIA, mit der NSA,
dem deutschen BND?
Nun deckt ein Geheimdienstdossier
eine globale Operation
einer unglaublichen Dimension auf.
Das Dokument heisst Minerva
und stammt aus dem Archiv der CIA.
Das ist schlicht
die wichtigste Spionageoperation,
die jemals stattgefunden hat.
Doch Mitte der 90er-Jahre
bringt dieser Mann
die gross angelegte
Spionageoperation fast zu Fall:
Die Verhaftung des Schweizer
Geschäftsmannes Hans Bühler im Iran
belastet die Beziehungen ...
Hans Bühler,
Topverkäufer der Firma Crypto AG.
Neun Monate sitzt er
in einem iranischen Gefängnis.
"Wir wissen, Sie sind ein Spion."
"Sie verkaufen Schlüsselcodes
dieser Firma."
"Wenn Sie heute Mittag nicht reden,
Sie können jetzt zu Mittag essen,
dann brennen wir Ihnen
die Augen aus."
Die "Rundschau" ist nah dran
an der Affäre Bühler ...
Sie haben also gar nichts am Hut
mit Nachrichtendiensten?
Nur als Kunden natürlich.
... kann aber keine Beweise liefern.
Von Manipulation
kann keine Rede sein?
kann nur jemand sprechen,
der diesen Dingen
sehr naiv gegenübersteht.
Unsere Geräte
sind nicht manipulierbar.
Nach dem "Rundschau"-Interview atmen
die ausländischen Geheimdienste auf.
Fast wäre alles aufgeflogen.
Es war knapp. Sehr knapp.
Die Operation läuft weiter.
Die Geschichte beginnt mit dem Ende
des Zweiten Weltkriegs.
Die Nazis sind besiegt.
Die Amerikaner
hatten einen wichtigen Vorteil.
Sie waren den Nazis
immer einen Schritt voraus,
weil sie deren Kommunikation
lesen konnten.
Sie knackten die Chiffriergeräte.
Diese verschlüsseln die getippten
oder gemorsten Nachrichten,
bevor sie verschickt werden.
Damit niemand sie abfangen
und mitlesen kann.
Doch nach dem Kriegsende standen
die Amerikaner vor einem Problem:
Vorher hatten
die US-Nachrichtendienste
mit mathematischen Verfahren,
mit guter Kryptologie
einen Grossteil der Kommunikation
knacken können.
Dann stellten sie auf einmal fest:
Da gibt es ein schwedisches Genie,
das Chiffriergeräte herstellt,
die extrem schwer
oder gar nicht zu knacken sind.
Das Genie: Boris Hagelin.
Die Amerikaner
wollen ihn auf ihre Seite ziehen.
Seine unknackbaren Chiffriergeräte
sollen nicht dem Feind
in die Hände geraten.
Hagelin gehört zu d e n Experten,
wenn es
um sichere Kommunikation geht.
Vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
und auch noch in den 50ern
war es eher
eine kleine Zahl von Leuten,
die diese sehr spezielle Technik
verstanden. Die kannten sich alle.
So kennen sich auch
die Kryptologen der US-Geheimdienste
und Boris Hagelin.
Sie schlagen ihm einen Deal vor.
Er willigt sofort ein.
Das ist, als ob eine kleine Gruppe
eine spezielle Magie kennen würde.
Und die sprechen sich ab, wie diese
Magie kontrolliert werden soll.
Die Magie, das ist die Kryptologie,
das Herz einer Chiffriermaschine.
Mithilfe ausgefeilter Algorithmen
werden Nachrichten verschlüsselt
und gehen so als Kauderwelsch
durch die Kanäle.
Wer die Algorithmen kennt,
besitzt die Macht.
Diese Macht will Boris Hagelin
den Amerikanern geben.
Es gab natürlich auch
einen elementaren Grund
für die positive Einstellung
gegenüber den Vereinigten Staaten.
Den Grund nämlich,
dass die Vereinigten Staaten
das Hitler-Regime
in die Knie gezwungen haben.
1952 zieht Boris Hagelin
in die Schweiz.
In der Garage dieses Hauses in Zug
installiert er die erste Werkstatt
seiner Firma:
Er nennt sie Crypto AG.
In die Schweiz kommt er nicht nur,
um Steuern zu sparen,
ihn stört in Schweden
noch was anderes:
die strengeren Exportrestriktionen.
Die neutrale und liberale Schweiz
scheint ihm der ideale Standort
für sein Business.
Die junge Firma wächst rasant.
Die klügsten Köpfe
tüfteln an neuen Geräten,
schmieden ausgefeilte Algorithmen.
Man verkauft in die ganze Welt.
Ein Patent nach dem anderen
wird angemeldet.
Die Firma
geniesst einen exzellenten Ruf.
Mitte der 60er-Jahre
zählt sie bereits 180 Mitarbeiter,
und in Steinhausen neben Zug
wird ein grosszügiger Firmensitz
erstellt.
Es ist für viele eine Ehre,
bei der Crypto AG zu arbeiten.
Das erzählt auch Bruno von Ah,
ein Entwicklungsingenieur,
der 27 Jahre
Chiffriergeräte mitgestaltete.
Man hatte das Gefühl, die Crypto
sei eine topmoderne Firma,
technologisch an der Spitze,
weltweit anerkannt
als gute Chiffrierfirma.
Es war eine Fabrikhalle,
etwa 30 m breit, 50 m lang.
Man hatte
an seinem Arbeitsplatz 2,5 m,
wo man Messgeräte, Pläne usw.
abstellen konnte.
Alle hatten das Gefühl:
"Wir als Schweizer Firma
in einem neutralen Staat,
unabhängig von Grossmächten,
tun für die ganze Welt
etwas Schlaues."
Was Bruno von Ah damals nicht weiss:
Die meisten Chiffriergeräte, die
das Werk in Steinhausen verlassen,
haben eine eingebaute Hintertür.
Vom Gründervater Hagelin
und den Amerikanern ausgeheckt,
den Mitarbeitern gegenüber
verschwiegen.
Die Swiss Made Quality
verkauft sich äusserst gut.
Die Neutralität der Schweiz
war geradezu der Garant
für den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
der Crypto AG.
Bald stehen
in vielen Regierungsbüros,
in Botschaften
und Armee-Hauptquartieren
Fernschreiber und Funkanlagen -
abgesichert mit Verschlüsselungs-
geräten der Crypto AG.
Mit Aufklärungsflugzeugen
und ihren riesigen Ohren
fangen die Amerikaner täglich
Tausende geheimer Botschaften
aus der Luft.
Alles was über Crypto-AG-Geräte
verschlüsselt wird:
Sie können es mitlesen.
Die Zusammenarbeit mit den
Geheimdiensten wird immer enger.
NSA und CIA
mischen sich nun auch ein,
wenn neue Maschinen
entwickelt werden.
Sie entwerfen die Algorithmen,
die Crypto AG,
also Boris Hagelin, übernimmt.
Ende der 60er-Jahre
ist Boris Hagelin
schon längst im Pensionsalter.
Es stellt sich die Frage,
wie es weitergeht mit der Firma -
und dem geheimen Deal.
Mit Bo Hagelin jr. gab es natür-
lich einen potenziellen Nachfolger.
Er hat aber sehr deutlich gemacht,
dass er die schmutzigen Geschäfte
seines Vaters
nicht weiterführen würde.
Bo Hagelin jr. leitet
das Nord- und Südamerika-Geschäft,
ist die meiste Zeit
weit weg von der Firma,
äussert sich aber
immer wieder skeptisch.
Schlussendlich entscheidet sich
Hagelin sen. gegen seinen Sohn
und für einen Verkauf.
Es entsteht ein Seilziehen
zwischen Nachrichtendiensten:
der amerikanischen CIA,
dem westdeutschen BND
und dem französischen Geheimdienst.
Schlussendlich passiert das, worüber
die Welt bis heute spekuliert hat,
was aber nie ganz
ans Licht gekommen ist.
Das Geheimdienstpapier
bringt endlich Klarheit:
Der westdeutsche Geheimdienst BND
und die CIA kaufen 1970 gemeinsam
die Crypto AG:
Ab jetzt
ist die Firma fest in den Händen
ausländischer Geheimdienste.
Gegen aussen weiterhin getarnt
als normale Schweizer Firma.
Ein Blick ins Handelsregister zeigt:
Hagelin sen. tritt 1970
sofort aus allen Ämtern zurück,
und seinem Sohn Bo - dem Skeptiker -
wird die Prokura gestrichen.
Dann gab es
eine verschlungene Konstruktion
über eine Treuhandanstalt
in Liechtenstein.
Die Gewinne wurden aus Liechtenstein
nach München transferiert.
Dort wurden sie
von BND-Mitarbeitern abgeholt,
zur Hälfte in bar,
und CIA-Leuten
in einer Münchner Tiefgarage
wie in einem schlechten Film
im Koffer ausgehändigt.
Hagelin jr. -
damals wohnhaft in Amerika -
war scheinbar
der einzige eingeweihte Gegner
dieses unheimlichen CIA-BND-Deals:
Selbst der Vizepräsident des BND
ging davon aus,
dass Bo Hagelin
nicht Opfer eines Unfalls,
sondern eines nachrichten-
dienstlichen Mordes wurde.
Man erzählt sich,
Hagelin sen. hätte noch viele Jahre
den Tod seines Sohnes
aufzuklären versucht - erfolglos.
Die Operation Minerva
umschwebt bis heute
ein schwer durchdringbarer Mantel
des Schweigens.
Er redet als Erster und Einziger:
Bernd Schmidbauer,
ehemaliger Staatsminister
unter Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl,
zuständig für die Geheimdienste.
Ich würde sagen, es war
eine sehr gelungene Operation.
Man hat Informationen bekommen,
die man nur auf einem solchen Weg
erhalten konnte.
Es ist wichtiger denn je,
an Informationen zu kommen,
geheime Pläne zu kennen.
Denn die Narben von zwei Kriegen
sind längst nicht verheilt.
Die Welt
ist geteilt in Ost und West.
Angst dominiert die Politik.
Die Gesamtschau war wichtig,
damit man eine Übersicht hatte.
Die Nachrichtendienste haben gezielt
mit anderen Methoden gearbeitet:
mit einem Mikrofon unter dem Auto,
im Hemd usw.
Das war ja viel präziser,
weil unmittelbarer.
Aber um einen Überblick zu haben:
Da wird irgendwo
ein Manöver angekündigt,
das wir nicht identifizieren können.
Bedrohlich - ja oder nein?
Dann sieht man den Verkehr
zwischen allen,
und dann weiss man,
was sich abspielt in der Welt.
So trägt
die kleine Crypto AG dazu bei,
dass die ausländischen Geheimdienste
im grossen Stil wissen,
was sich wo abspielt.
In Steinhausen
bricht derweil eine neue Ära an:
Jetzt gehört die Firma
voll und ganz der CIA und dem BND.
Die neuen Besitzer bestimmen alles.
Neue Kaderleute werden nun sogar
in das Minerva-Geheimnis eingeführt,
direkt von der CIA.
So auch Sigmar "Mickie" Grützmann.
Ehefrau und Tochter erinnern sich
an den Familienausflug in die USA.
Sie haben damals
natürlich keine Ahnung,
worauf ihr Mann,
ihr Vater sich einlässt.
Das war der Eintritt.
Das war für mich
natürlich faszinierend.
Ich war noch nie geflogen,
dann gleich First Class.
Ich auch nicht.
Mit dem Hubschrauber über Manhattan.
Von einem Flughafen zum anderen
mit dem Hubschrauber.
Es war ein Militärhubschrauber.
Wir waren acht Tage
allein in Washington.
Und mein Mann, der war immer weg.
Er sagte immer nur,
er habe geschäftliche Besprechungen.
Du hast gesagt,
du hättest ihn mal abgeliefert,
da seien so graue Tore gewesen.
Ja, aber er sagte nicht,
wohin er geht.
Das war eine Strasse
im Wald oder im Park
und da war ein Tor,
das war bestimmt 20, 30 m breit.
Da habe ich ihn abgeliefert
und dann ist er gegangen.
Also mit dem heutigen Wissen
denke ich,
dass die CIA
ihn darauf vorbereitet hat,
was er in dieser Firma zu tun hat.
Er wurde angeworben und eingeweiht
um die Crypto-AG-Kryptologien
vor misstrauischen Kunden
zu verteidigen.
Mickie Grützmann reist
mit seinen Geschäftsleitungskollegen
zu Kunden in aller Welt: Syrien,
Afghanistan, Pakistan, Ägypten.
Gemeinsam lügen sie die Kunden an:
Ihre Geräte seien
die abhörsichersten auf dem Markt.
Es funktioniert: Die Crypto AG
wird immer erfolgreicher.
Die reine Weste der Crypto wurde
eigentlich nie infrage gestellt.
Und so prägen diese manipulierten
Maschinen die Weltgeschichte mit.
Wohl auch den Militärputsch
in Chile.
Dokumente aus dem Bundesarchiv
beweisen:
Die Dirección de Inteligencia
erwirbt Anfang der 70er-Jahre -
bewilligt
durch das Militärdepartement -
für 500'000 Fr. Crypto-AG-Geräte.
Seit Kurzem ist eine demokratisch
gewählte Regierung an der Macht,
eine linke Regierung
unter Salvador Allende.
Er verlässt sich auf die neutralen
Schweizer Verschlüsselungsgeräte,
um abhörsicher zu kommunizieren.
Doch die USA wollen keine sozia-
listische Regierung in ihrer Nähe.
Mit umfangreichen Aktionen
unterstützt die CIA
einen Militärputsch 1973.
Experten gehen davon aus,
dass das Abhören der Crypto-Geräte
den USA wichtige Vorteil verschafft.
Der Putsch gelingt -
von einem Tag auf den anderen
fällt Chile in eine Diktatur.
Es folgen viele Jahre gewaltsamer
Herrschaft von Augusto Pinochet.
Andersdenkende werden gefoltert,
verschleppt, getötet.
Die Informationen,
die die Amerikaner -
und auch die Deutschen -
durch das Abhören
der Crypto-Verschlüsselungsgeräte
abfangen können,
helfen den Grossmächten, die Welt
nach ihrem Gusto zu gestalten.
Das war eine der dreistesten,
skandalösesten Operationen.
Mehr als 100 Länder der Welt
zahlten Milliarden,
um sich ihre eigenen Geheimnisse
stehlen zu lassen.
Eigentlich ziemlich unverfroren.
Die Crypto AG spielt ihr doppeltes
Spiel immer professioneller.
Die neuen Technologien erlauben
immer raffiniertere Hintertürchen
und die Kunden vertrauen -
gerade in politisch heiklen Zeiten -
der Firma aus der neutralen Schweiz.
Die haben uns eigentlich fast
mit dem roten Teppich empfangen.
Es hat ihm, glaube ich,
auch gefallen,
weil er so viele Einsätze
auf der ganzen Welt hat.
Man kam, um Geräte zu demonstrieren.
Man kam, um Probleme
mit ihnen zu diskutieren.
Die alte Chiffriermaschine,
versteckt im hintersten Winkel
ihres Dachbodens:
Malaika Hug hat sie als Andenken
an ihren Vater aufbewahrt.
Ruedi Hug war viele Jahre für die
Crypto AG als Verkäufer unterwegs.
Auch er berichtete oft,
wie er von Generälen und Offizieren
hofiert wurde.
Darunter waren auch Diktatoren
wie Muammar al-Gaddafi in Libyen.
Er hat erzählt,
dass er ihnen Geräte verkauft,
ihnen zeigt,
wie die Geräte funktionieren,
dass er Schulungen macht.
Es waren sehr ranghohe Offiziere,
es waren ranghohe Beamte.
Man fühlte sich fast als VIP.
Wir kleinen Ingenieure
wurden fast wie VIP empfangen.
Für die amerikanischen Geheimdienste
ist das eine unglaublich
wertvolle Operation.
Es trägt zu einer ganzen Reihe
wichtiger Erfolge bei.
Es trägt zu einem
Nahost-Friedensabkommen bei.
Das war 1978.
Der Nahostkonflikt spitzt sich zu.
Israel und Ägypten
bekriegen und misstrauen sich.
Verhandlungen zwischen den Ländern
sind zäh.
Bis zum Auftritt der USA
als Verhandlungsführerin.
Jimmy Carter lädt den ägyptischen
Präsidenten Anwar as-Sadat
und den israelischen
Ministerpräsidenten Menachem Begin
zu sich nach Camp David ein.
Hier haben Sie also Menachem Begin,
Sie haben Anwar as-Sadat.
Die hassen sich. Die wollen nicht
miteinander sprechen.
Also sind sie in zwei verschiedenen
Zentren, zwei verschiedenen Häusern.
Sie haben Delegationen.
Die schicken die Kommunikation
hin und her.
Jimmy Carter
muss diese Leute zusammenbringen.
Ägypten stand natürlich in der
arabischen Welt nicht alleine da
und musste sich bei Staaten
wie Saudi-Arabien
und anderen Mitgliedern
der Arabischen Liga vergewissern,
wie weit man in den Verhandlungen
gehen darf.
Und diese Vergewisserungsprozesse
liefen natürlich über verschlüsselte
diplomatische Kommunikation.
Das bedeutet: Jimmy Carter spielt
Poker und kann alle Karten sehen.
Thank you very much.
Der langersehnte Frieden
im Nahen Osten ist zum Greifen nah
und US-Präsident Jimmy Carter
der Held.
Im Minerva-Dokument
steht dazu auf Seite 56:
Die USA markieren in dieser Zeit
ihre Rolle als Weltpolizist
immer stärker
Und viele
gestehen ihnen dies auch zu.
Also der Ami war toll.
Wir hatten ja damals alle
den Rappel: Der Westen ist gut.
Die Amerikaner waren ja damals
noch eine überhöhte Nation.
In Steinhausen glauben noch immer
die meisten Mitarbeiter die Legende,
dass sie hier die unknackbarsten,
die sichersten Verschlüsselungs-
geräte der Welt produzieren.
Manchmal kommt der Direktor
mit Bauplänen zu den Ingenieuren
und sagt: "Hier, ich habe wieder
einen Plan von Gott erhalten."
Da er nicht verraten darf, woher die
Mathematik, die Algorithmen stammen.
Doch einigen Mitarbeitern
wird die Sache langsam unheimlich.
Mein Vater
hat die Geräte zusammengebaut
und wusste auch wirklich,
wie sie funktionieren.
Die Entwicklungsingenieure
der Crypto AG
haben nach bestem Wissen
und Gewissen versucht,
unlösbare Chiffriergeräte zu bauen,
sichere Algorithmen zu basteln.
Ich bekam ein Schema, um einen
Chiffriergenerator zu bauen.
Als er lief
und der Lochstreifen gestanzt war,
kam der Direktor und sagte:
"Wunderbar,
den nehme ich gleich mit."
Ich habe mich dann gefragt:
Was macht unser Direktor
mit diesem Lochstreifen?
Er muss so ein Gerät
nochmals angeschaut
und festgestellt haben,
dass etwas anders ist.
Da bekam man schon das Gefühl,
es müsse noch andere Leute geben,
die daran interessiert sind,
was der Chiffriergenerator macht.
Das kam ihm seltsam vor.
Die einzige Erklärung,
die er dafür hatte, war,
dass die Geräte manipuliert sind.
Sie mussten eigentlich ahnen,
dass da höhere Mächte in ihre
gute Technik eingegriffen hatten.
Bei der Entwicklung eines
innovativen Geräts für Militärs –
dem MCC 314 -
wird die Sache noch klarer:
Bei jedem Entwicklungsschritt
mischen sich deutsche Stellen ein.
Wöchentlich fahren in Steinhausen
Mitarbeiter des deutschen
Nachrichtendienstes vor -
getarnt als Berater von Siemens -
und verlangen Änderungen.
Der Entwicklungschef
schöpft Verdacht
und rechnet die Pläne
übers Wochenende genau durch.
An einem Montagmorgen
kam er in mein Büro und sagte,
er habe herausgefunden,
wo das Hintertürchen ist.
Doch ein Mitarbeiter,
der die Hintertür kennt -
den versteckten Zugang auf
die hochgradige Verschlüsselung -
ist nicht gern gesehen
bei den wahren Besitzern der Firma,
den ausländischen Geheimdiensten.
Der Entwicklungschef ist
von einem Tag auf den anderen weg.
Das geschah von heute auf morgen.
Man hatte das Gefühl:
"Dieser Mann ist zu gefährlich."
"Wir müssen ihn weghaben."
Wenn es Bern
nicht sowieso schon längst wusste,
spätestens jetzt
wissen es die Behörden.
Sie werden
über den Verdacht informiert,
dass ausländische Nachrichtendienste
über eine Schweizer Firma
Spionage betreiben.
Wie reagieren die Schweizer Behörden
darauf?
Nehmen sie die Vorwürfe ernst?
Sind sie gar alarmiert?
Wir suchen Antworten
im Bundesarchiv.
In der Fichenabteilung
finden wir den Beleg.
Der entlassene Entwicklungschef
erklärte bereits Ende 70er-Jahre
den Behörden:
Die Behörden erstellen den
Fall Code, die Spur verliert sich.
Mit der Hilfe
der Mitarbeiter des Bundesarchivs
stossen wir auf eine einzelne
mysteriöse Karteikarte.
Zu finden darauf ist keine
Information, aber einer Instruktion.
Ich habe hier eine Fiche,
die ich als leere Fiche
bezeichnen würde.
Wo normalerweise die Ereignisse,
die die Bundesanwaltschaft
beobachtet, aufgelistet sind,
vielleicht noch mit einem Verweis
auf die entsprechenden Dossiers,
finden sich keine Einträge.
Ausser: "Fiche bei K, Aktion Code".
"Bei Anfrage nicht erwähnen,
dass Fiche existiert."
"Hingegen Meldung an L oder K,
von wem Anfrage eingegangen ist."
Was die Behörden sonst zum Fall Code
hatten, bleibt ein Geheimnis,
die Suche endet in einer Sackgasse.
Weitere Dokumente
zur Aktion Code sind verschollen.
Man muss davon ausgehen, dass
die Schweizer Sicherheitsbehörden
den nachrichtendienstlichen Einfluss
von BND und CIA auf die Crypto AG
sehr genau kannten.
Die Bundespolizei
wurde allerdings aktiv
und ging den Anschuldigungen
des entlassenen Crypto-AG-
Entwicklungschefs nach.
Das war vor meiner Zeit.
Das war 1977-1979.
Dort hatte man
ein Gerät von einem Land,
das angeblich
hätte manipuliert sein sollen,
ausleihen können.
Der Befund war am Schluss,
dass es keine Hinweise
auf Manipulationen gab.
Handfeste Beweise fehlen
oder werden nicht weitergereicht.
Trotzdem ist davon auszugehen,
dass in Bern spätestens jetzt
einzelne Personen Kenntnis
von dieser Spionageoperation haben.
Ich halte die Arbeit
der Schweizer Dienste für sehr gut,
auch in dieser Zeit.
Und ich nehme an,
dass sie nicht uninformiert waren.
Die offizielle Schweiz
will offenbar keinen Eklat.
Prüft aber ihre eigenen Geräte,
die sich als sicher herausstellen.
Laut CIA erhält die Schweiz seit
Beginn nicht manipulierte Geräte -
ohne Hintertür,
eine Art unausgesprochener Deal.
Also lässt man die Crypto AG
in Steinhausen weiter gewähren.
Auch in der Firma
verfliegt die Aufregung rasch.
Neue Geheimnisträger übernehmen.
Die späten 70er und frühen 80er
sind rauschende Geschäftsjahre.
Die Crypto AG wird Weltmarktführerin
und den Mitarbeitern
wird einiges geboten.
Crypto hat gut gezahlt,
Bonus gezahlt.
Ich kann mich an Feste erinnern,
als wir in Steinhausen waren.
Man konnte essen,
es gab viel für Kinder.
Wir waren unheimlich oft weg -
zu Festen und Essen und so.
Ihr wart viel weg.
Man hatte ein schönes Leben
bei der Crypto.
Die Mitarbeiter werden umgarnt.
Ein firmeneigenes Fussballfeld,
ein Tennisplatz entstehen,
sogar ein Segelboot
wird angeschafft.
Diese Firma war ein Teil des Lebens.
Nicht nur für meinen Vater,
sondern ich würde sagen,
für die ganze Familie.
Es ist auch die Zeit,
in der Hans Bühler angestellt wird.
Der enthusiastische Weltenbummler
und Funk-Amateur
gilt als Verkaufsgenie.
Einer, der mit den schwierigsten
Kunden umzugehen weiss.
Sagt auch Minerva:
"Bühler war einer der
aufsteigenden Sterne der Crypto AG."
Er liebt seinen interessanten
und aufregenden Job,
der ihn in die ferne Welt bringt.
Alleine den Iran besucht er 25-mal
für die Crypto AG.
Doch die Mitarbeiter wissen nicht,
welcher Gefahr sie sich aussetzen.
Hans Bühler wird es später
im Iran schmerzhaft erfahren.
Was den Angestellten
verheimlicht wird:
Sie sind nicht nur
für ihre Schweizer Firma unterwegs,
sondern auch
für ausländische Geheimdienste.
Viele dieser Verkäufer sind nicht
in die Operation eingeweiht.
Sie wissen nicht, was sie verkaufen.
Sie werden faktisch
als Agenten eingesetzt -
ohne zu ahnen,
dass sie Agenten sind.
Er weiss,
dass er quasi ein Agent ist.
Mickie Grützmann, angestellt,
um mit seiner Fachkompetenz
die Fragen skeptischer Kunden
zu überstrahlen.
Doch seine Doppelrolle
belastet ihn bald.
Ich musste ihn immer
in Zürich abholen
und habe oft gemerkt:
Er hat eine Alkoholfahne.
Ich denke, dass er da vielleicht
irgendwas betäubt hat.
Die Familie sieht, wie er leidet,
ohne zu wissen, warum.
Die CIA stuft ihn bald als
unbrauchbar für die Operation ein.
Das ist ein brutaler Satz,
finde ich.
Mickie Grützmann muss immer wieder
misstrauische Kunden täuschen.
Auch das damalige Jugoslawien
hatte gerade
für viele Hundertausend Franken
Chiffriergeräte erworben.
Das neuste Modell.
Involviert sind sogar Leute
aus der Armeespitze.
Dann kommt ein Anruf aus Belgrad:
Der Produktspezialist soll kommen,
sie hätten ein Problem.
Die Jugoslawen haben
wie viele andere Staaten
eigene Krypto-Kapazitäten
entwickelt, Experten herangezogen,
die sehr schnell erkannt haben,
dass sie von der Crypto AG
unsichere Geräte bekommen hatten.
Diese Schlaumeier
hatten es herausgefunden.
Die jugoslawische Armee droht,
wenn die Ingenieure
keine Lösungen präsentierten,
würden sie
das schmutzige Geheimnis enthüllen.
Das wäre ein Horrorfall gewesen.
Krisensitzung der Firmenleitung.
Einen Monat später
reist Bruno von Ah nach Belgrad
mit Lösungsvorschlägen im Koffer.
Er verrät ihnen,
wie die Hintertür zugemacht,
das Gerät
sicher gemacht werden kann.
Dann hat man nichts mehr gehört.
Bis der Jugoslawienkrieg losging.
Während es da rasselte
und geschossen wurde,
kam noch mal
ein Geschäftsleitungsmitglied zu mir
und fragte mich:
"Wie habt ihr die Geräte
ausgeliefert nach Jugoslawien?"
Im Hinterkopf war natürlich
sofort der Gedanke:
Da gab es Stellen, die probiert
haben, den Schlüssel herauszuholen.
Und dann ist es halt
nicht mehr gelungen.
Spätestens jetzt
wird Bruno von Ah klar,
dass hier noch andere -
ziemlich grosse Mächte
ihre Finger im Spiel haben.
Dass Geheimdienste versuchen,
die Kommunikation der Serben
während der Kriegswirren abzuhören,
und dies nicht geht.
Eine schwere Bürde
für die eingeweihten Führungskräfte
wie Mickie Grützmann.
Er, der genau weiss,
was im Hinterzimmer
alles abgesprochen wird,
welch abgekartetes Spiel
hier eigentlich läuft.
Er musste rechtfertigen,
dass das ja alles in Ordnung ist,
er musste lügen,
das war seine Aufgabe.
Das konnte er nicht.
Daran ist er kaputtgegangen.
Er war inadäquat.
Mickie Grützmann
hält dem Druck nicht stand.
Er wird gefeuert.
Zu Hause erzählt er lediglich,
dass er die Betrügereien
der Amerikaner nicht mehr aushält.
Später dann, hier in Stuttgart,
hat er es dann gesagt,
dass die Crypto mit der CIA
und dem BND zusammenarbeitet.
Belastend ist für Mickie Grützmann
nicht nur,
dass er zum Lügen gezwungen wurde.
Er hat wohl auch gespürt:
Was er tut, kann
weltpolitische Auswirkungen haben.
Maschinen, die er verkauft,
stehen plötzlich im Zentrum
von Auseinandersetzungen.
Hinzu kommt, dass die Operation
immer skrupelloser wird.
Man verkauft die Crypto-Geräte
nun auch an befreundete Länder:
den Vatikan, Italien, Irland,
Spanien und sogar an die UNO.
Ich kann feststellen:
Wenn es um Krieg und Frieden ging,
waren bestimmte Methoden
einfach notwendig.
Die Aktion
hat sicher dazu beigetragen,
dass die Welt
ein Stück sicherer geblieben ist,
und man viele Informationen hat,
die auf anderen Wegen
nicht beschafft werden konnten.
Doch diese sog.
beschafften Informationen
stellen die Geheimdienste auch immer
wieder vor moralische Dilemmas.
Z.B. im Fall von Argentinien.
Auch das argentinische Militärregime
unter General Jorge Videla
ist Kunde der Schweizer Firma.
Durch die Crypto-Geräte können BND
und CIA aus erster Hand erfahren,
wie die argentinische Militärjunta
mit Regimegegnern umgeht.
Wie sie verschleppt,
misshandelt und ermordet werden.
Die Minerva-Dokumente gehen
wahrscheinlich weiter als alles,
was wir bisher gesehen haben,
wenn es darum geht zuzugeben,
wie viel die westlichen Regierungen
von diesen Gräueltaten wussten.
Und es ist überraschend,
dass es da nicht mehr Widerstand
der Europäer und Amerikaner gab
gegen diese Vorgänge in Argentinien.
Woche für Woche werden Gefangene
in Flugzeuge gepfercht
und über dem offenen Meer
lebendig hinausgeworfen.
So sterben Tausende.
Dem brutalen Regime fallen
mehr als 30'000 Menschen zum Opfer.
Seit über 40 Jahren
demonstrieren die Mütter
der Verschleppten und Ermordeten.
Ein Protest auch gegen den Westen,
der nichts unternahm,
um das Morden zu stoppen.
Nora Morales de Cortiñas
ist von Anfang an dabei.
Ihr Sohn Carlos wurde 1977 entführt.
Die Regierungen wussten vom Horror,
der Folter,
den Entführungen von Babys,
von schwangeren Frauen.
Sie wussten das und unternahmen
nichts, um die Situation zu beenden.
Die Diktatur
dauerte acht bis neun Jahre
wegen der Komplizenschaft
dieser Länder,
die mit der Diktatur
Geschäfte machten
auf ziviler, kirchlicher
und ökonomischer Ebene.
Ihr Sohn
bleibt bis heute verschwunden.
Es ist nicht ungewöhnlich,
dass Geheimdienstler
in einem schrecklichen
moralischen Dilemma stecken.
Handelst du,
verrätst du deine Operation.
Dann gibt es
keine Informationen mehr.
Auch er ist ein Rädchen
in der gross angelegten
Geheimdienstoperation.
So absolut ist das Ruedi Hug
sicher nicht bewusst.
Aber zu sehen,
was auf der Welt alles geschieht,
und zu wissen, dass Crypto-AG-Geräte
an vielen dieser unruhigen Orte
im Einsatz stehen,
lässt ihm keine Ruhe.
Das hat ihn schlussendlich
sehr beschäftigt.
Und er hat sich
nicht mehr wohlgefühlt damit,
etwas zu verkaufen,
von dem er wusste,
dass da bewusst
etwas daran gemacht wurde,
obwohl er nicht genau wusste,
was gemacht wurde.
Das war dann
schlussendlich auch der Auslöser,
wieso er der Crypto
den Rücken zugewendet hat.
Ich bin im Nachhinein -
nach allem, was passiert ist -
gottenfroh, dass er das gemacht hat.
1992, als das mit Hans Bühler
passiert ist, dachte ich nur:
Oh mein Gott,
das hätte mein Vater sein können.
Die Verhaftung des Schweizer
Geschäftsmanns Hans Bühler in Iran
belastet die Beziehungen
zwischen der Schweiz
und der islamischen Republik Iran
schwer.
Hans Bühler: der Starverkäufer.
Er geht auf Routinebesuch zu seinem
Stammkunden, dem iranischen Militär.
Die Iraner,
die sich politisch besonders alleine
und isoliert fühlen,
vertrauen seit vielen, vielen Jahren
der Crypto AG, den Geräten
aus der neutralen Schweiz.
Nach einer
Chiffriergeräte-Präsentation
wird Hans Bühler verhaftet,
in ein Militärgefängnis gebracht
und intensiv verhört.
Vorwurf: Spionage.
Für die Mitarbeiter der Crypto AG
ein Schock.
Auch, weil sich die Firma
gegen aussen
wenig um Bühler zu kümmern scheint,
ihn hängen lässt.
Wir hatten unser Augenmerk
erstmals darauf gerichtet,
dass Hans Bühler
eine bessere Unterbringung
im Gefängnis im Iran erhielt.
Jetzt wird ihnen klar,
dass im Grunde jeder Verkäufer
der Crypto AG
eine potenzielle Geisel ist,
ein potenzieller Gefangener,
jemand, der gefoltert werden könnte.
CIA und BND befürchten,
dass die Operation auffliegt,
ihr grosses gemeinsames Geheimnis
Minerva ans Licht kommt.
Das wäre das Ende.
Während der ganzen Bühler-Geschichte
ging mir immer durch den Kopf:
"Zum Glück kennt Herr Bühler
die Details dieser Ebene nicht."
"Er hat keine Kenntnis
von Hintertürchen."
Das Ungewisse:
Kommt er wieder zurück?
Was passiert mit ihm dort unten
und wenn er zurückkommt,
was ist er dann für ein Mensch?
Das Verhör ging so weit,
bis man ihm die Pistole an den Hals
oder an die Stirn legte.
"Jetzt sag endlich,
sonst macht es Klick!"
Die wollten von Bühler
das Eingeständnis,
dass die Crypto AG
von westlichen Nachrichtendiensten
manipulierte Geräte verkauft.
Und das hätte
nicht nur den Iran bewegt.
Die Iraner wussten genau: Das bewegt
die gesamte arabische Welt.
Nach der ersten Gerichtsverhandlung
kommt endlich Bewegung in den Fall:
Die Iraner fordern 1 Mio. $ Kaution,
damit Bühler nach Hause kann.
Doch der damalige Geschäftsleiter
der Crypto AG - Michael Grupe -
will nicht zahlen.
Während sich auch die CIA weigert,
wird der BND nervös -
und entscheidet.
Der Bundesnachrichtendienst
musste alles unternehmen,
damit seine Verwicklung in die Firma
nicht offenkundig wurde,
d.h.,
er musste auch das Geld hinlegen.
Und so geschieht es auch:
Deutschland nimmt 1 Mio. $ in
die Hand und kauft Hans Bühler frei.
Nach über neun Monaten Haft
lassen ihn die Iraner endlich gehen.
Ein gezeichneter Mann
kommt am Flughafen Zürich an.
Ich war in eine Zelle eingesperrt,
3 m auf 2 m,
auf einem Steinboden
mit zwei Wolldecken,
während drei Monaten.
Es war sehr schwer.
In einem späteren "Rundschau"-
Beitrag beschreibt Hans Bühler
seine traumatischen Erlebnisse
im Teheraner Gefängnis.
"Sie sind ein Spion, Sie kommen
unter dem Deckmantel Ihrer Firma,
der Firma Crypto, in den Iran.
Für nachrichtendienstliche Zwecke."
"Sie haben
ein Spionagenetz aufgebaut."
"Sie verkaufen Schlüsselcodes
dieser Firma."
Die furchtbarsten Anschuldigungen.
"Sie lügen und Sie arbeiten
noch für andere Dienste."
Und dann sagte man mir:
"Wenn Sie heute Mittag nicht reden,
können Sie jetzt zu Mittag essen,
dann brennen wir Ihnen
die Augen aus."
"Und dann werden Sie singen
wie ein Vogel."
Man liess mich auch
neben der Folterkammer sitzen,
um zu hören, was hier vorgeht.
Dann kam ich dran.
Und dann, weil noch
ein Geistlicher dabei war ...
Für mich war das wie beim Ableben.
Die letzten Sakramente kommen jetzt.
Doch Hans Bühler
entkommt dem Horror.
In Steinhausen wird er
feierlich willkommen geheissen.
Die Crypto AG veranstaltet
einen Apéro für ihren Starverkäufer.
Die Geschäftsleitung, alle sind da.
Doch kurze Zeit später
wird Bühler entlassen.
Das Vertrauensverhältnis
sei gestört.
Das müssen Sie sich mal vorstellen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich
sehr schwer, sich das vorzustellen.
Sie sind neuneinhalb Monate
im Gefängnis, ohne zu wissen, warum,
kommen nach Hause und
ausser dem heuchlerischen Apéro,
den man gemacht hat als Firma
für den Bühler,
vor der gesamten Belegschaft ...
Aber der Gedanke dahinter war:
"Weg mit Bühler. Weg mit ihm."
Hans Bühler kann es nicht fassen,
kann nicht verstehen.
Seine Fragen werden drängender
von Tag zu Tag.
Er beginnt zu recherchieren
und kommt einem Teil der Wahrheit
hinter der Crypto AG auf die Spur.
Bei seiner Recherche
kann er auf die Unterstützung
seines guten Freundes Ruedi Hug
zählen.
Papi nahm sich fest vor,
Hans zu helfen.
Wollte wissen, ob es irgendeine
Möglichkeit gibt, ihm zu helfen.
Er schrieb Briefe an Nationalräte,
nahm Kontakt mit Leuten auf
in der vermeintlichen Hoffnung,
dass es irgendwas gibt,
wo man helfen kann.
1994 schreibt Journalist Res Strehle
mit Bühler ein Buch.
Darin beschuldigt Bühler
die Crypto AG,
mit Geheimdiensten zu kooperieren.
Diese Anschuldigungen
lösen eine mediale Welle aus.
Die Firma ihrerseits
bemüht sich kräftig,
das Bild einer unabhängigen
und unbeeinflussten Firma zu wahren.
Geschäftsführer Michael Grupe
stellt sich in der "Rundschau"
den heiklen Fragen
und lügt dem Journalisten Garbely
direkt ins Gesicht:
Die geheime Aktionärin
ist die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
bzw. der Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Das ist natürlich völliger Unsinn.
Sie haben also gar nichts am Hut
mit Nachrichtendiensten?
Nur als Kunden natürlich.
Von Manipulation
kann keine Rede sein?
kann nur jemand sprechen,
der diesen Dingen
sehr naiv gegenübersteht.
Unsere Geräte
sind nicht manipulierbar.
Wie die CIA im Minerva-Dokument
auf Seite 80 schreibt,
ist sie stolz auf Michael Grupes
Leistung im Fernsehen.
Aufatmen bei den Hintermännern
der Crypto AG.
Die Gefahr scheint abgewendet.
Doch Hans Bühler geht
mit seinen Vorwürfen auch nach Bern.
Jürg Bühler leitete damals
die Ermittlungen der Bundespolizei.
Der heutige Vizedirektor des
Nachrichtendiensts erinnert sich.
Ich dachte: "Ja,
das ist ein gewichtiger Vorwurf,
den man sicher
sauber abklären muss."
Die Bundespolizei
nimmt Vorabklärungen auf,
trifft rund 20 aktuelle
und ehemalige Mitarbeiter.
Auch Bruno von Ah
wird in ein Café bestellt -
für ein Hintergrundgespräch -
und steht vor einem grossen Dilemma.
Jetzt haben wir
so lange geschwiegen.
Soll ich jetzt oder soll ich nicht?
Wenn man von Hintertürchen redet,
haut man die Firma in die Pfanne,
wenn man nichts davon sagt,
ist Bühler nicht geholfen.
Die CIA beobachtet das Hin und Her
in der Schweiz sehr genau
und zittert, wie im Minerva-Dokument
zu lesen ist:
Hier drin sagt er genau,
was mit den Geräten passiert ist.
Doch die "Rundschau"
konnte mit mehreren
ehemaligen Mitarbeitern sprechen.
Alle berichten von einer seltsamen
Stimmung bei diesen Befragungen.
Als ob es die Bundespolizisten
nicht wirklich hätten hören wollen.
Ähnlich empfand es Bruno von Ah,
als er sich
schlussendlich entschied, zu reden:
Ich sagte dem von der Bundespolizei,
dass es
ein mögliches Hintertürchen gebe.
Das kann ich so nicht bestätigen.
Wir hatten Leute, die sagten,
sie hätten von der Hintertür gehört,
aber sie nie beschreiben konnten.
Tatsache war, dass uns niemand
präzise Auskunft geben konnte
oder wollte.
Und nur gestützt auf Gerüchte
und Hörensagen
hat man eben nicht genügend
Verdachtsmomente.
Ich sagte dem von der Bundespolizei,
dass es
ein mögliches Hintertürchen gebe
und wenn die Bundesanwaltschaft
mir garantiere,
dass sie verhindern können,
dass Crypto an mich gelangt,
dann würde ich aussagen.
Etliche der Crypto-AG-Mitarbeiter
packen bei den Befragungen aus
und scheinen
auf taube Ohren zu stossen.
Auch fahren die Bundespolizisten
nach Steinhausen.
"Die BuPo-Beamten
besuchten die Fabrik
und sprachen mit Grupe und anderen,
schienen aber nicht sehr
daran interessiert zu sein,
in die Tiefe zu gehen."
"Es war eindeutig
ein Pro-forma-Besuch."
Ein paar Tage später
kam die Antwort,
sie könnten das nicht garantieren.
Ich weiss nicht, wie man dort
noch besser hätte hinschauen können.
Wäre es ein Strafverfahren geworden,
hätte man andere Mittel
zur Verfügung gehabt.
Das ist klar,
aber man kann ein Strafverfahren
nicht einfach aus einem
schlechten Gefühl heraus eröffnen.
Für den Geheimdienstexperten gibt es
mind. einen Grund anzunehmen,
dass die Schweizer Behörden gar
nichts herausfinden d u r f t e n .
Jedenfalls nicht offiziell.
Hätten die Schweizer Bundespolizei,
der Schweizer Nachrichtendienst
oder der Verteidigungsminister
offiziell die Auffassung vertreten,
die Crypto AG
ist eine Tochter von BND und CIA,
und sie verkauft
manipulierte Geräte -
die Schweizer Behörden hätten
das Unternehmen schliessen müssen.
Das wäre natürlich
die absolute Kriegserklärung
an CIA, BND und NSA gewesen.
Das konnte sich die Schweiz
überhaupt nicht leisten.
Ja, ja.
Irgendwann fragt die Bundespolizei
nicht mehr weiter
und die Bundesanwaltschaft
entscheidet,
es bei der Voruntersuchung
zu belassen.
Gut, gut.
Es wird still um den Fall Crypto AG.
Aus Bern hörte Bruno von Ah
nie wieder etwas.
Wahrscheinlich war es so,
dass auch die Bundesanwaltschaft
das Gefühl hatte:
Schweigen ist Gold.
Für die Schweiz
scheint die Sache erledigt,
doch in Deutschland
macht man sich Gedanken.
Wie weiter
mit dieser ultraheiklen Operation?
Bernd Schmidbauer hatte damals den
Bundesnachrichtendienst unter sich.
Er sagt, für sein Land
sei zu viel auf dem Spiel gestanden.
Deutschland
war frisch wiedervereint,
dieses neue Bild
wollte man schützen.
In der Abwägung des Risikos
mit solchen Massnahmen
und im Aufkommen der Fairness
anderen Staaten gegenüber
und bei abnehmender Bedrohung
war es eine
von uns richtige Entscheidung,
dass wir neue Wege gehen
und dass wir mit solchen Operationen
nicht in die Zukunft gehen wollten.
1993 verkauft
der deutsche Nachrichtendienst
seinen Teil der Crypto AG
an die CIA.
Sie ist ab jetzt
alleinige Besitzerin der Firma.
In Zürich muss sich Hans Bühler
vor Gericht verantworten.
Die Crypto AG will ihm verbieten,
je wieder öffentlich
Anschuldigungen zu machen.
Einen Tag
vor der definitiven Verhandlung
einigt man sich aussergerichtlich.
Bühler erhält Schweigegeld.
Seither hat er kaum mehr geredet.
Malaika Hugs Vater
hat noch lange dafür gekämpft,
dass das dunkle Geheimnis
der Crypto AG ans Licht kommt.
Vor vier Jahren ist er verstorben.
Er war ein extremer -
wie soll ich sagen?
Er hatte einen wahnsinnigen
Gerechtigkeitssinn.
Es machte ihm zu schaffen,
dass er die Wahrheit am Schluss
nicht ans Licht bringen konnte.
Mickie Grützmann stirbt jung.
Die Crypto-Zeit hinterlässt ihn
als gebrochenen Mann.
Er erholt sich nie wieder.
Seine Familie
erfährt erst im Minerva-Papier,
was er wohl durchlitten hatte,
auch später noch.
Er hat gesagt:
"Redet nicht so viel über
die Crypto, wir werden beobachtet."
Gar nichts.
Wir dürfen gar nichts erzählen.
Auch das Wort CIA,
das hätte gar nicht fallen dürfen.
Das hat er wirklich gesagt.
Nachher haben wir gedacht,
das ist ein Suffkopf,
der spinnt sich da
im Rausch etwas zusammen.
Wir haben gedacht, er spinnt.
Man hat's nicht ernst genommen.
Und das tut im Nachhinein
schon auch weh.
Hans Bühler, der Weltenbummler,
verlässt die Schweiz nie wieder.
Im Dezember 2018 stirbt auch er,
wahrscheinlich ohne jemals die
ganze Wahrheit erfahren zu haben.
Und der Gründervater Boris Hagelin?
Er stirbt 1983 und hinterlässt
seine Memoiren in einem Safe.
Sie werden in 13 Jahren öffentlich.
Nun ist ihm Minerva zuvorgekommen.
Kurz vor seinem Tod
soll er mal gesagt haben:
"Ich bin der grösste Spion
des 20. Jh."